foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
another
[Music]
big
dreams
so watch me break
[Music]
cause all this way please
each
year of the disguise
[Music]
and you're still sleeping
cause all this way you
[Music]
do
not very
much
[Music]
foreign
was a wild ride wasn't it uh big thanks
to everybody who voted for that song and
for me to flow to it because uh it was
definitely a great treat also if you're
curious the POI that I'm using in this
video are sock POI by well soccerboy you
can grab a set for yourself by heading
on over to sockpoy.store these are made
by Katya stockinova of one day spin Fame
and they are currently my favorite
daytime POI also big thanks go out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flowfests flow toys
juggling calling pyro Terra light toys
spin balls and Ultra POI for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special Franks thanks to
non-business friends of the channel That
is lame utrinsky and Becca becklinen
thank you both so very much for your
support for my work my channel and my
mission
also thanks go to these nice people
right here because without them uh the
videos on this channel would not be
possible these are my flow patrons over
on patreon they and the people that's
down in the description helps make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support
a few out there watching would like to
become a supporter and you're not
currently you can sign up to do so over
at patreon.com drexfactor POI uh there
you can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you if you'd like to check out
some of my other flow videos I'm going
to go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of them down in the description
as well as up here on screen if you are
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this top video here based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a look
as well thanks so much for watching this
video make sure to get outside and flow
today and I will see you with a new
video very soon peace